[Music]
hey welcome everyone i'm richard hi i'm
vidya we're really glad you joined us
here today we're gonna have a lot of fun
talking tech and i wish you could be
here with us personally but we're live
at least and that means we can kind of
say anything like i could say google
should bring back google reader and i'm
still working here so that's awesome if
you have other hot takes you want to
share some feedback put it in the chat
we can see that stuff live right now so
keep it coming
if you can't see the live interactivity
please click on the blue
join live interactive experience button
on the next website and we'll see you on
the other side
for those of you just joining us from
the spotlight session you heard about
some of our new product announcements
including anthos for vms anthos
multi-cloud api and the google
distributed cloud yeah awesome in the
next 15 minutes we're actually going to
show you all of these in action which is
great so here's what we're going to do
together first we're going to migrate
something and demonstrate how to get
some new value from an old system by
moving vm based applications to a newer
containerized platform and we'll start
by showing you how to run a legacy app
in a server-less platform sir buckle up
video
next we'll create we'll build a new
experience for customers through our ai
powered software and then we'll deploy
with some brand new deployment tools
unique to google cloud love it finally
we're going to be expanding our
deployment targets we're not just
shipping the cloud anymore but extending
that awesome path to production to other
public clouds and even closer to your
customers at the edge all right so let's
switch some things up shall we
i now work at simple shops probably
because that google reader crack
so let's pretend that i am the director
of i.t at this company symbol shops and
like many of you our global business has
been shifted because of increasing
demands online
and at the same time we have some
problems so old software was never meant
for all the customer load we're putting
on it now it's holding us back we're
trying to offer mobile experiences
real-time stuff we have to do it as
quick as we can and look i can't rewrite
everything so how do we reduce some cost
and add some capabilities to that
existing software a little easier that
much too much effort so i want to start
with a smart migration approach you know
i want a repeatable efficient way to
move old systems to newer stuff maybe
even a serverless one but simple shop
needs help from our trusted partners at
google cloud help video you're my only
hope
i got you richard
so our fit assessment tool which you can
see here
is initiated from the google cloud
console
it helps us understand what can be
automatically migrated and which
workloads are going to be most
successful in their new home it's unique
to google cloud and saves you time
by pointing our migrate service at a set
of over 2000 virtual machines in our
on-prem vsphere environment we just
generated a fit assessment for the
workloads running in each of those vms
and remember
these vms could be running on-prem in
google cloud in aws or in azure so now
let's take a look at the result of the
assessment
see here we have a graphical view of our
most likely candidates for migration
this tool is particularly good at
detecting compatibility for older java
applications like java ee application
servers
now that we've assessed let's migrate
using our migrate service i'm taking a
java app running on websphere in an
on-prem vm and generating a container
image
that can run on any of our container
services all via automation
and you can see here that the classic
java app is now served up by our only
pay for what you use serverless
container product cloudrun
wow i love that so this is great let me
make sure we knows what we just did
there i mean i don't have to manage all
these partially utilized virtual
machines anymore because you
containerized it and i've offloaded some
of the operating system management out
to patch os's anymore that's awesome
and you've actually given me access to
brand new functionality and saved me
money by running in a modern platform
like cloud run so you just took a
classic java app and ran that on the
serverless platform
it's that's pretty wild stuff if you
like that tell us in the chat that you
have a need for putting some of your
older systems in these newer platforms
all right so next up let's create some
new value and get that to google cloud
so simple shops has some problems we
want to solve we have a app that tracks
some of the store performance but it
runs in vms and it needs some serious
modernization to support all those sort
of new customer experiences and can keep
us competitive so this means upgrading
functionality and even changing how we
could deliver it to production it's a
curbside pickup super hot right now how
do i add functionality then to count how
many customers did curbside pick up each
day that seems really important nvidia i
don't know can you help me with this one
yes of course i can so richard what does
your current app consist of well thank
you for asking our current app has a
mongodb database with multiple services
to track orders and pickups we actually
want to add new services and data to
capture and analyze that curbside pickup
info and to make that happen we could
look at historical footage from the past
day and count the pickups and do some
analysis later this looks like a great
opportunity to do two things first
we're going to add google cloud ai to
process video footage and capture
metrics
second we'll containerize these
workloads and put them on a continuous
delivery pipeline so that it's easy to
keep making changes
i like that so if you do this then we
actually know how many customers are
doing curbside pickup maybe even how
long they were waiting and i think
you're going to fix them on my path to
prod and keep it make it easy to kind of
package and keep changing the software
over and over again i love that yes
absolutely check it out so google cloud
vision api can detect vehicles in this
footage to determine how well curbside
pickups have been going at each location
so now let's write some code and deploy
the updated app to google cloud this is
exciting and i'm hoping all our audience
is excited too i'm using visual studio
code here but i could easily use
intellij or any jetbrains ide
and using the no cost cloud code plugin
i can easily browse google cloud
services add them to my app and then
code and test this container-based app
you are the fastest coder i've ever seen
that was remarkable so it was pretty
simple too i like that so now that
everything's working locally how would
they then deploy this to the cloud let
me show you
first we need to package up this app
into a container
you probably want your developers
spending time writing code not docker
files and we can help with that
i'll show you how we like to package
containers and while i'm doing that
audience tell us how do you package your
containers
so here is our poll and we have four
options in our poll so i'm hoping you'd
actually pick it up
awesome
so cloud build is a serverless build
tool that many customers use for
continuous integration
we also now support industry standard
cloud build packs to package up our app
into a container image automatically and
push it to artifact registry
artifact registry stores your container
images in regional repositories and here
you see that we automatically scan for
vulnerabilities
that's neat what else do we use artifact
registry for this is i haven't seen as
much about that can you tell me a little
bit about that yeah so while we use
artifact registry for storing docker
container images richard we can also use
it for storing all your language
specific artifacts in one place for
instance we just went ga with java
node.js and python packages using the
maven npm and pi pi repository formats
respectively that's pretty cool so while
we're waiting for the poll results
looking at some of the chat i saw some
questions about how do we do day two
management of migrated workloads i think
the migrate tooling gives you a
container image that now i could
download to my desktop i can run in
different places i have different ways
to run that some other questions about
again thinking about how do we
how do we migrate to uke and cloud run i
think these tools are pretty cool that
they can actually take an app and run it
in either one which is pretty great
and i think we're seeing the poll
results coming yeah looks like the
results are in
and um it's amazing that a lot of folks
are already automating today and they're
automating via dockable commands in ci
pipeline that's excellent
so now that we have a container in the
registry i think it's time to deploy it
so to deploy our app let's use the new
google cloud deploy service
a continuous delivery service for
deploying containerized workloads
while the service is containerized and
could run in gke or cloudron
the app is fairly coupled to our mongodb
infrastructure running in kubernetes and
is part of our multi-cloud strategy
so let's target one of our gke autopilot
clusters
gk autopilot is the fully managed
kubernetes service where google cloud
provisions
scales
upgrades and troubleshoots the cluster
for me
here we see a deployment pipeline that
helps us manage release candidates and
environments
cloud deploy helps us manage promotion
and rollout across these environments
and once the app is deployed to gke
autopilot you can start using it from
each retail store that you have
you kick this all off with a push to get
and also you manually approve
a final promotion to production
in fact i'm going to have someone drop
the url in the chat window now so that
you can see it for yourself it all works
just like magic that's cool must be true
you put the link there that's great so
it's awesome so from development to
packaging deployment i mean i think
personally this is the best set of
integrated tools for services and
building containers that i've seen so i
think that's awesome
so we're also seeing some other folks in
the chat talking about some of these
components as well and what they're
seeing for migrating the apps and
hopefully clicking links and trying to
break the app we just deployed
all right so now that we've just taken
that existing app we added ai
functionality we dramatically changed
the knowledge that each of our stores
has about the customer experience that's
pretty cool
indeed isn't it richard what else do you
want to throw my way i think we got some
time so we've acquired a few other
retail chains who use different clouds i
mean nobody's perfect right so
at the same time this app needs to run
in more places so that each of those
stores can analyze curbside pickup
behavior regardless of what cloud
they're using so i guess video my
question for you is how do i run this
app everywhere
yeah that's a great question richard and
we do have a solution for consistency
across any environment
check out how we do it through anthos
with the new multi-cloud api
we can provision these clusters right
from the google cloud cli or console in
other clouds including aws and azure
where you already had some applications
installed see here that i'm using a
single gcloud command to create a gke
cluster on azure
here
we've deployed gke clusters to google
cloud
and microsoft azure i'm managing it all
from google cloud and i'm even able to
centrally deploy and view workloads to
any of these gke clusters
that's wild thanks vidya so
you're actually putting gke i think it's
the best kubernetes in the public cloud
anywhere i want it i mean that's that's
really powerful stuff i love that new
azure support and again each store
manager whatever cloud they're using can
actually see a report at the end of the
day to know how they performed on
curbside pickup that was the goal all
right but now you're making me think
that we could probably do more right we
could expand some of our thinking here
and maybe respond to the customer
demands in real time could we actually
evolve from that after the fact analysis
of parking lot footage to maybe improve
the experience in real time by that i'm
thinking of could i run this ai model
against live camera footage instead of
recorded stuff and maybe be able to do
something with it as it happens
of course as always new new challenges
emerge if we think of something like
this so off the top of my head we'd have
to somehow customize this ai model right
because now i have to identify the
number of cars in motion how many are
waiting is the curbside lot picking up
and i probably want to operationalize
that model and move it closer to the
store because i'm processing data in
real time so latency matters and then i
want to integrate all that insight i'm
getting with the existing in-store
systems for the managers to use so they
can move their employees around so
that's a lot of stuff i don't know can
you help me with that
we can so i'm calling in my colleague
gabriele he has been working with one of
your on-prem locations richard in austin
and he can explain how we improve your
software for edge scenarios hi gabriella
hi vidya and hello everyone uh glad to
join you richard uh by the way congrats
on your role and symbol
um what you're asking for can be solved
with our uni allowance google
distributed cloud at the edge as such
you mentioned it brings the best of
google cloud to the edge it consists of
a fully managed cpu gpu optimized
platform with a common set of google and
third party applications
you build once and deploy anywhere as an
example here at some of your stores
so let's get going
we're going to add real-time
intelligence with ai models and process
the data locally to reduce video latency
let's get this running on the edge in
each store
so we start out by first using google
vertex ai
uh and so we train the engines and the
visual ai objects recognition and
classification models in the central
cloud
here we are monitoring the progress and
accuracy of the model
and as you can see the train models can
now be packaged into container images
right those container images can be
ready to be deployed anywhere including
at the edge
this case will be targeting five
different symbol stores
from the google console we can choose
the kubernetes clusters running at
specific edge locations across all the
single stores
once we pick those clusters we can
deploy the vision ai mode that we
created to each edge in the store
and manage those edge clusters just like
any other gke
the symbol operations team has the same
familiar experience
only now
simba can also leverage the gpu
optimized google distributor cloud to
achieve better performance at lower
latency
and as a fully managed service
distributed cloud comes with the same
integrated google cloud operation and
management capabilities that you're used
to
here
you know symbol can monitor the health
and state of their store deployments
managed capacity scale all of these
using the familiar google console and
backed by google sre practices
so as you can see uh in the video here a
real-time analysis of curbside service
level from the live footage
led to real-time insights for single
shops to build a better customer
experience at each store
specifically this new model at the edge
is recognizing cars in motion telling
you when the curbside pickup loss are
filling up
all executed in real time
so what do you think richard back to you
this is great you're amazing gabriella
that's i can't believe you built all
that all by yourself so this actually
gives all our store managers really new
insight into the real-time customer
experience letting those stores allocate
staff and people based on real-time
customer demand that's awesome so for
the audience out there i'm actually
interested what sort of apps do you
think about running at the edge is that
a real use case you're considering what
sort of things might run there
all right so i do love what you built
for me i don't want to be uh you know
greedy but i want a little more this app
isn't an island right you're doing some
cool ai containerized based stuff but
there's a lot of things already at that
store location right our notification
services other back office it's all in
vms so
now that we have to integrate our new ai
customer service app these vm-based
systems am i signing up for completely
different management experiences across
containers and virtual machines or can
you do something for me
oh absolutely not you're we're gonna
provide you the same experience uh with
the new antos for vms we can actually
help you bring those virtual machines
into the antus platform and manage them
the same way we manage containers
so see here
that i've moved a set of virtual
machines under antos management
which now gives me a straightforward way
to move and modernize existing apps at
the
edge wow that's awesome there's nothing
you can't do gabriella that's great so
what's powerful here is that all the
google-powered fleet management in
google cloud other clouds at the edge is
all based on anthos with one open
control plane for wherever those
workloads run this simplifies our
operations a lot
that open foundation makes hiring
developers and operates a heck of a lot
easier all right so last challenge for
you symbol has this growing european
presence but some of those regional
stores operate with some restrictions on
data sovereignty i don't want to
sacrifice all the amazing development
and management capabilities that you
nvidia have showed me today so is this a
lost cause or do you have something for
me
uh yes we have something for you uh and
as we announced it yesterday with the
new google distributed cloud hosted
we can use a single hardware and
software stack from google cloud but now
with local compute and a local control
plane it runs not only our container and
vm workloads but also the data and
application services we care about
you could run this
as an example with the original hoster
fully air-gapped and have local stores
connect directly to that
uh one open modern platform from
whatever you want to operate
i'm sold you've done it
so that's pretty cool so same anthos
control plane tech but also local
services in this fully air gap setting
that's great stuff thanks gabriela
appreciate you joining us here and video
did you like that i did actually and
gabriella that was amazing and i'm sure
our audience thinks so as well
over the last 15 minutes we've shown you
how google cloud offers a world-class
experience for building new software or
modernizing what you have
our solutions for container-based apps
are second to none and we're now making
it possible to extend those terrific
services to wherever you need us to be
all right thank you all for joining us
vidya gabriela as well this was terrific
stuff and thank you out there for the
chat and the engagement it was awesome
to see that so now stay tuned for the
live q a coming up next we're going to
talk about everything from the spotlight
all the way through this demo get your
questions in there and we'll be
answering it live thanks so much bye
bye
you